exactement la pollution nous avons fait
québec donne déjà des crédits d'impôt
pour l'achat d'une voiture électrique ou
hybride à ottawa devait faire la même
chose
accorder des crédits d'impôt pour les
voitures hybrides ou électriques et de
soissons laon réduire effectivement les
gaz à effet serre au québec qui est le
plus d'autos électriques mais simple et
comme je viens de dire le feu derrière
investi 1 milliard de dollars chaque
année pour développer les nouvelles
technologies la technologie verte cette
une c'est un bon investissement pour le
système de transport poursuivant système
de réglementation en collaboration avec
les états unis pour ce secteur
et ça va continuer à réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre un ami
je dirais que ce n'est pas très bonne
idée que vous avez prêté 500 millions de
da leur à vox moyenne en avril
mais quand même nous sommes au début une
relance l'évolution économique
une révolution technologique vers
nouvelle économie verte ou le mans nous
avons crié déjà une ou deux fois dans
les technologies propres que dont le
savez et aimez mieux déjà mais c'est
mesquer
c'est une occasion en or pour le québec
de participer à ça nous avons déjà le
plus grande cohorte la plus grande
proportion d'énergies propres et
renouvelables de toute autre juridiction
en amérique du nord
profitons-en on a des technologies de
pointe on peut développer des véhicules
électriques
ici il faut en faire une priorité mais
il faut aussi croire un rôle positif
pour le gouvernement
monsieur harper n'y croit pas on sait
qu' un énorme dépense qui va se faire à
travers le monde la dent nous on va être
à l'avant plan un champion pour le
secteur de fabrication mais c'est trop
dur le parti libéral du canada propose
des investissements records dans des
infrastructures vertes devrait milliards
de dollars sur 10 ans on a aussi des
investissements à dans l'économie verte
dans la recherche
adam l'augmentation de notre capacité de
compétitionner de façon propre partout
dans le monde dans notre développement
c'est ce que le parti libéral a un plan
pour faire les autres continuent jose
d'en parler nous on va agir
immédiatement